I would now like to show you how to
calculate the moment of inertia of a
typical continuous body let's consider a
rigid rod very thin and what we want to
do is calculate the moment of inertia of
this body about the center of mass let's
say the body is of length L and it has
total mass M now recall that the moment
of inertia about the center of mass we
defined as an integral of DM R squared
integrated over the body now our
challenge today is to understand exactly
what all these terms are in this
expression what is DM what is R and what
do we mean by an integral over the body
so now let's do a step wise
interpretation of each term the crucial
thing is to introduce coordinate systems
so let's choose a coordinate system and
let's put the origin at the center of
mass now the most important thing is
that we're going to do an integral so we
need to introduce the integration
variable and that's the hardest part of
setting up integrals so what we want to
do is arbitrarily choose an element DM
so there's our element DM and here's our
integration variable it's a distance X
from the origin so that's the
integration variable now there's two
things when we set up the interval R is
equal to that integration variable R is
abstract in this expression but in this
concrete realization it is the
integration variable the second place
the integration variable shows up is in
DM DM is the mass in this small element
but if we want to express that in terms
of our integration variable we have to
express it in terms of the differential
a DX so DM mass is equal to the total
mass per unit length we're assuming the
rod is uniform times the length DX of
our small piece and now we've set up the
two pieces that are crucial and all we
have to think about now is what does an
integral mean well an integral me
that we're dividing up the piece into a
bunch of small elements and we're adding
the contribution of each small element
so in particular when we write I see M
equals now we can write it as M over L
DX
that was our DM and the distance of DM
from the point for computing the axis is
x squared now the question is what is
our integration variable doing well X is
going from minus L over 2 that's at this
end to x equals plus L over 2 on the
other end so we add X minus L over 2 x
equals plus L over 2 and now we've set
up the integral for the moment of
inertia and the rest is just doing an
integral recall that the integral of DX
x squared is X cubed over 3 and so this
integral then simply becomes I see M
equals M over L X cubed over 3
evaluating from the limits minus L over
2 to x equals plus or L over 2 again
when you evaluate the limits what we get
is M over L we have to put in L over 2
cubed divided by 3 minus minus L over 2
cubed divided by 3 and that's 1 over 2
cubed is 1/8 divided by 1/3 that's a
twenty fourth twenty fourth minus minus
20 fourth is a twelfth and so what we
get for I see M is M over L 1/12 L cubed
or 1/12 ml squared is the moment of
inertia about the center of mass of our
rigid rod and this is a measure of how
the mass is distributed about this axis